[BLANK_AUDIO]
I wonder where Walter is.
It's taking him a really
long time to get back.
>> Whoa, are you okay?
>> I'll be okay.
>> Walter, what happened to you?
>> Well,
after my normal wrist workout routine,
I was trying to organize my
shopping list for the big benefit.
But now that we've got about 20 users,
it's been much harder to find my lists.
I just had to keep scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling.
>> It's okay.
Let it out.
>> Well, then a bunch of users who
didn't even have anything to do with
the benefits started
adding a bunch of items.
Maybe they were confused.
Or maybe they were bored and
just trying to find someone to torment.
In any case,
I had to delete each item one by one.
Then I had to go in and
manually add 50 items.
My wrists started hurting and
I typed through the pain.
>> My gosh.
What is wrong with you?
Can't you see he's in pain?
We can't celebrate.
>> I'm sorry Walter.
This actually is sounding like
something we have to add.
A way for
users to kind of limit who can see and
edit items on their shopping lists.
>> Yeah, and some sort of sorting
functionality might not be a bad
idea either.
>> Well, with Firebase queries, we
could tackle the sorting functionality.
Sharing might be a bit more difficult.
We'd have to think about designing
the database as the user base grows.
We could look at that in version 0.4.
>> Yeah, that sounds like a great idea.
I'll get looking at that right now.